il ya plusieurs façons dans laquelle les
risques et les vulnérabilités pour les
défenseurs persiste ou sont encore pire
dans le contexte actuel un c'est que le
pont d'any n'a pas arrêté les opérations
des compagnies donc à pour les
défenseurs qui avait des risques déjà ça
persiste pour les personnes ou les
communautés qui se défend ce qui voulait
dire non à un certain opérations et les
mécanismes qu'ils utilisent souvent pour
pouvoir défendre leurs droits n'existent
plus
on les personnes les individus sont en
confinement peut manifester etc ou de
bonnes raisons mais les opérations des
compagnies persiste même si dior à cette
opposition
il ya aussi de nouveaux risques à à
cause du pont d'any 1 pour les personnes
qui travaillent les risques aux
travailleurs un anglais personnes les
courts vidéos qu'on connaît qu'on a
montré lors d'un webinaire c'était de
caractère qui est un qui travaille avec
le 1 1 un groupe de travailleurs en
bangladesh et par la dette de la
difficulté que les travailleurs
expérience présentement dans la
production des vêtements ambac
bangladesh il y a soit les risques pour
les personnes qui vont au travail un de
prévoir les équipements de protection et
cetera
mais un des grands problèmes qu'ont
compact présentement c'est que à cause
du pont d'amis on a beaucoup de
compagnies ont simplement annulé leurs
commandes
mais c'était pas des futures commandes
c'était des commandes qu'on a déjà a
commencé à fabriquer que des personnes
avaient déjà travaillé
et que les compagnies disait non on va
plus acheter cela et on va prier je peux
pas des compagnies canadiennes dans ce
cas des compagnies qui avaient fait des
commandes spécifiques ni les radicaux
des compagnies au bangladesh et ça oui
il y avait les compagnies canadiennes et
d'autre part dans le monde
oui et donc donc c'est un peu ça les
risques et les vulnérabilités uns et les
autres les autres expériences qu'on
entend parler c'est que les défenseurs
des droits de la personne
souvent à bout bush d'un place à
d'autres pour garder sa sécurité
et dans le contexte actuel au moulin on
ne peut pas se déplacer
celle notamment comme ça donc on voit
par exemple en colombie les défenseurs
des droits de la personne qui sont plus
à risque on a plusieurs en habit
plusieurs personnes qui ont été tués un
dans les dernières semaines c'est pas on
ne sait pas si c'est lié directement aux
activités des compagnies ou non mais ces
risques existent et on sait que les
risques pour les défenseurs des droits
de la personne qui à défendre leurs
droits face aux compagnies sont plus à
risque que d'autres